direction à présent les pates du parc à
chambr et les tours pour une rencontre
insolite entre desponis et les résidents
ouais nous l'avons vu en début de
semaine à blouis par exemple avec la la
chaîne squeeze hein qui enchante le
quotidien de patients de l'hôpital la
présence d'animaux est très vertueuse
dans cette épad de tour ce sont donc les
de chambres et les tours ce sont donc
les les poneets qui sont amenés dans les
locaux même de l'établissement pour
apporter réconfort aux résidents stimulé
par la présence donc de ces équités
équidé Jau ça c'est super Candy et
Griffond d'or sont les stars d'un jour à
la résidence du Parc entre caresse
baiser ou gratouille pour certains
résidents c'est l'occasion de se
remémorer des souvenirs d'ENT temps
attends moi je faisais de la classe on
a une une charette après pu j'ai fait
des concours à ballon jeais cl F là il y
avait des photos je
m'habillais je regardais avec des
chapeaux
parfois difficilement perceptibl les
équidés jouent un rôle important de
stimulation sur les personnes âgées
toucher ou odorat lesessens se met en
éveil il y a il y a un véritable
apaisement même sur des des gens qui
vont être beaucoup plus calme beaucoup
plus posé ou très discret il se passe
quelque chose dans les yeux faire
déambuler des poneiss dans un épad n'est
pas chose simple même si Candy et
Griffond d'or sont habitués à ce genre
d'activité les ascenseurs ne leur font
pas peur
sauf quand ils sont un peu étroits mais
pas de panique Marie et Quentin
réalisent en amont tout un travail de
dressage pour préparer leurs poneys qui
finissent par être rodés notamment quand
c'est l'heure du dîner en fait l'aliment
pose pas problème c'est que souvent les
résidents vont venir mettre les mains
sous le nez sous la bouche et vous avez
vu nos poneet jamais ils essayent
d'attraper leurs doigts en fait parce
qu'ils ont pas l'habitude d'être nourris
à la main apaisé par la présence de
personnes âgées ils sont plus calmes
sûrement moins fougueux Candy et
Griffond d'or end prochaines visite
prévu dans 3
mois